je vous remercie les sénateurs ont
commencé l'examen du projet de loi sur
les radios privées locales les fameuses
radios libres
le texte a été présenté par le ministre
de la communication georges fillioud
l'essentiel du débat portera sans doute
sur la question de la publicité une
question difficile a reconnu le ministre
monsieur le ministre pour certains le
projet de loi sur les radios locales
privées va trop loin pour d'autres il ne
va pas assez loin vous restreignez les
radios locales alors il est un peu
difficile de s'y retrouver
il faut d'abord savoir qu'ils sont c'est
certain moi je suis en train de
présenter au nom du gouvernement de la
gauche
un projet de loi qui vise à ouvrir une
liberté qui jusqu'ici étaient interdites
en faveur des petites stations de radio
privées locales
voilà à partir du moment où une liberté
publique est en cause c'est au
législateur de se prononcer et 7
également à lui des fixer les limites de
son exercice
bien qu'ils me reprochent de ne pas
aller assez loin
c'est paradoxal mais c'est comme ça
ce sont les représentants de la droite
c'est à dire ceux là mêmes qui n'ont pas
bougé pendant des années qui ont toutes
accepté dans le domaine de la radio de
télévision et en particulier qui ont
accepté même voulu ils ont voté la loi
qu'il fallait pour ça que les problèmes
de ces radios qu'on appelait à l'époque
pirates soient réglées par l'envoi des
gendarmes et les crs et ensuite par les
tribunaux eh bien ce sont ceux là mêmes
qui aujourd'hui vient de me dire vous
n'allez pas assez loin quelle sera la
place de la publicité dans ces radios
dans la publicité va dominer sûrement
les débats la question n'est pas encore
tranchée
l'avis du parlement à cet égard est
précieux et le problème se pose entre
pas de publicité du tout ou bien une
publicité réglementée dans des
conditions précises et avec moyens de
contrôler le sénat se prononcera demain
l'assemblée nationale d'ici à quelques
jours
cette heure un choix sur lequel il est
normal que le parlement exprime